[Música]
[Aplausos]
la tierra está siendo destruida sin
misericordia
estamos terminando con toda la vida a
nivel planetario en el país y la ciudad
de mexico
esta ciudad está colapsando no hay agua
potable y por otro lado hay lluvias
torrenciales que han devastado colonias
enteras no hay territorio que sostenga
su crecimiento acelerado
milpa alta es la segunda alcaldía con
mayor extensión territorial pero es la
primera en conservar su totalidad como
suelo de conservación ambiental y
propiedad comunal sin embargo hoy en día
es asediada por los gobiernos en turno
que la miran como una reserva
territorial para el crecimiento urbano y
como reserva ambiental por los servicios
ecológicos que provee a la ciudad es por
este escenario que queremos compartir
con urgencia nuestras maneras de hacer
frente y resistir ante este escenario de
devastación
la responsabilidad de salvaguardar y ser
partícipes de este proceso de memoria y
resistencia y lucha por la defensa en la
tierra en los territorios es de todos no
importa tu geografía tu color sus formas
tus tiempos sus modos tu lengua y qué
puedes hacer tú para defender en tu
cotidianidad la tierra y los territorios
hace algunos años reconocí por primera
vez en mi cuerpo la herencia de las
abuelas sobre el cuidado del monte las
aguas el uso de plantas medicinales tés
y hongos de nuestro monte y después de
esta experiencia intuitiva me permite
invocar en la tierra espacios
espirituales de esos que te hacen
vomitar el dolor la rabia y la
indignación
cuando andamos en el monte cuando
caminamos la montaña y le lloramos todas
nuestras tristezas a los árboles y
decidimos sacar esas cargas de nuestras
cuerpos sentimos la energía en la tierra
calentada por el sol me pienso y
resignifica mi existencia y para mí esa
es una manera hermosa de resistir ante
este tiempo que nos ha tocado vivir
y en una de estas caminatas en la
montaña conocí por primera vez a nadie a
donají y a veronica
mujeres que al igual que yo habitan en
milpa alta y reconocen su existencia
desde políticas de identidad y cariño
radical
nosotras somos mujeres de mala cachete
pp como músico y como mujeres que somos
no sabemos hijas del agua del aire del
fuego del bosque todas nacidas de la
tierra y juntas hemos construido la
colectiva joven las comuneras de mil
palta espacio que nos ha permitido
participar en la vida pública de nuestra
comunidad incluidos los espacios de toma
de decisiones hemos asumido el rol de
hacedoras y constructoras de historia de
nuestros pueblos y de nuestras historias
y para mí caminar con más mujeres
defensoras de la tierra de los
territorios es brindar la posibilidad
para estar juntas es construir nos desde
un lugar cósmico y político común es
politizar nuestro cariño es fortalecer
las colectividades desde el amor y esa
es nuestra lucha
en este caminar con más mujeres hemos
aprendido a compartir nos con la
compañera de enfrente con la compañera
de al lado con la compañera que invita
con la compañera que enseña con la
compañera que abraza con la compañera
que admira nos tejemos con más mujeres
porque sabemos que es la única manera de
defender nuestras vidas la de nuestras
tierras y nuestros territorios
sabemos además que desde tiempos
coloniales hemos sido las mujeres de los
pueblos originarios quienes hemos
salvado y guardado los saberes de la
tierra que aún hoy permiten la
supervivencia cultural de nuestros
pueblos y de la ciudad de mexico
entonces porque no somos las comunidades
originarias quienes definimos la
política y agenda ambiental en la ciudad
y por el contrario ha sido el estado
quien ha creado políticas que nos miran
con desprecio que responden a los
intereses del capital y de los poderosos
intentan despojarnos de los elementos de
la naturaleza que hemos cuidado y
guardado de manera ancestral
una de las experiencias de la defensa de
la tierra y los territorios la podemos
ver en la historia reciente de mil palta
que está plagada de proyectos que
abanderan la muerte en los años 70 la
presencia de la papelera loreto y peña
pobre y las vías de alta tensión que
pretendían atravesar el monte comunal
el plan de ordenamiento
urbano en los años 90 la detención del
proyecto arco sur en el 2001 y más
recientemente la perforación del pozo en
miacatlán la nula consulta a la
comunidad para la construcción de un
verificentro y la poca claridad sobre el
uso del predio destinado un centro de
salud en villa milpa alta el intento de
militarización en chico mulco con la
presencia de la guardia nacional el
diseño y ejecución de políticas de
reforestación que no responden a las
necesidades del bosque sólo el 1 por
ciento del árbol reforestado sobrevive y
el creciente número de asentamientos
irregulares en suelo de conservación
ubicados en zonas de alto riesgo como
barrancas y terrazas
entonces cómo podemos formar esa primera
línea de defensa por el uso no
capitalista de los elementos de la madre
tierra
la propuesta que les traemos es la
organización es encontrarnos
reconocernos escucharnos abrazarnos
actos rebeldes y dignos
dejémonos conmover por la energía de la
tierra
reconozcamos los dolores de la madre
tierra en nuestras cuerpos porque así
como traen sus dolores pasados y
presentes también tienen su propia
medicina
dejémonos conectar con la intuición y la
espiritualidad es urgente traer al
presente el hilo de la memoria sanadora
como un acto político consciente
después transformemos ese dolor esa
rabia e indignación en acción esta lucha
es a la vez personal pero es a la vez
colectiva
apostemos por la construcción de
espacios de horizontalidad sin líderes
sin mandones ni mandonas
y después de encontrarnos y construir
colectivamente
imaginemos y construyamos maneras de
vivir en armonía con la tierra y los
territorios
la lucha por la defensa de la tierra y
los territorios y la defensa en nuestras
vidas es un mismo camino y es una misma
lucha
hoy quiero invitarte a que construyas
acciones colectivas cotidianas para la
defensa de la madre tierra y nuestra
existencia con ella
estoy convencida de que la única manera
de subsanar las fracturas que ha dejado
este sistema en nuestras comunidades y
nuestras vidas es crear y mantener
espacios de organización y encuentro
desde el diálogo horizontal desde la
creatividad desde la humildad desde el
amor desde las ganas de crecer y resonar
juntas
que lo que nos convoque que esté
presente que amamos y nos duele pero
también este futuro que amamos y que ya
no estamos dispuestas a que también nos
duela
este es un llamado a la organización
desde el amor reivindiquemos la alegría
sin perder la indignación
clásica mate
[Música]
[Aplausos]